oh my goodness you guys I am so hyped
now many of you know that I am a huge
Star Wars fan and I also tend to claim
that I'm a Jedi in training but aside
from that I freaking love collecting
things like all things my house is just
it's basically full of my Collections
and hobbies and this is where my new
friends at kryptoys came in and said hey
Justine we think that we've got
something that you might like and they
were so right so a huge thank you to
cryptoys for partnering with me on this
video and also giving me a few of what
I'm about to show you to give away to
some of you these are only for a limited
time so make sure you hurry so you can
get one
so here it is this is the kryptoys
website and this is where they have a
few collections of digital toys already
but they just launched this entire line
of Star Wars digital collectible toys
there are 15 various versions of Luke
Skywalker Princess Leia and Darth Vader
that you can collect each character has
five different Rarities the span from
common rare legendary Grail and Ultra
Grail and as a Star Wars nerd you will
see that the Rarities will span the
various Star Wars films so hopefully you
can pull one from your favorite movie
they are limited edition so they will
sell out and as you'll see on this pack
there's a little seal right here and
that signifies that this is a first
edition and won't ever be made again
there's actually a full-on unboxing
experience but there's a catch because
you can choose to leave your character
in its blister pack just like this so
it'll remain in mint condition but again
just like in real life if you do this
you won't be able to unwrap your toys
and watch them come to life they've all
got some signature moves you can see
them we'll their lightsabers or fire a
blaster but that is of course if you
unwrap it knowing the team of toys
I am really hoping that there's going to
be some fun Star Wars theme experiences
for our toys I asked they wouldn't
confirm any details but fingers crossed
I can't wait for that let me unbox one
for you so you guys can see what happens
so first you'll need to purchase some
holocrons and if you buy five you'll get
a golden ticket that will give you early
access to Future drops so here is one of
our holocrons and we are going to unbox
it now so we're going to be transported
and warped into light speed for this
entire unboxing process and it is about
to reveal are we gonna be on the dark
side on the light side What's it gonna
be and it looks like we are on the light
side and we have Luke Skywalker this
Luke is actually from Return of the Jedi
so he is a legendary character now here
this is where the decision has to be
made do we open it or do we keep it
sealed because much like in the real
world obviously going to be worth more
and the problem is though you can't
actually play with it and I am not one
to ever keep any of my toys inside of
the boxes so we're gonna unbox it right
now here we go Luke
[Applause]
it's such a magical experience oh my
goodness and again there are only a
limited number of these so once they
sell out they're gone shall we do
another one okay yeah I think we should
we're warping we're warping we're
opening up our holocron What's it gonna
be What's it gonna be and it looks like
we have Darth Vader except this is
actually Anakin and this is a rare
character and this is from Revenge of
the Sith okay do we do should we do one
more we should do one more let's do just
let's just do one more it's happening
it's happening
the suspense we are back on the dark
side and this my friends we have a
classic Vader and this one is actually
pretty common which I'm kind of excited
about because this Darth Vader character
is really just that it's a classic no I
haven't pulled one yet but if you are
lucky enough to get an ultra Grill here
is what they look like and hopefully one
of these days I can pull an ultra Grail
okay should we just unbox one more
before we go I think we should I think
we probably should I plan on doing a
live stream unboxing of some of these of
the ones that I've purchased so be sure
to stay tuned for that here we go What's
it gonna be oh it's
oh it's Ultra Grill layout just kidding
this is actually just a sample unboxing
video that they sent me to show you guys
what it looks like I do have my fingers
crossed though for you and hopefully
you'll be able to get one if you guys do
end up getting some of these be sure to
tweet me what you get I can't wait to
see them if you got curious about the
history of how kryptoys came to be their
founder will actually got a lot of
inspiration from his daughter well
thanks so much for joining me so you're
the founder of crypt toys can you talk
about like how this all got started
absolutely thank you Justine for for
having me so uh this all started with my
10 year old daughter Victoria this was
all inspired by her and her love for
surprise unboxing toys I was spending
hundreds if not thousands of dollars on
these toys
um but what I noticed is that she would
collect them she'd look for the rare
ones but then they would just kind of
accumulate dust in the corner of her
room and she'd never play with them
again after chasing after them so I had
the idea of what if we can combine the
idea of a toy make it a digital toy kind
of like a hybrid between a toy company
and a gaming company and if you could
fuse those two what possibilities could
you create so this started off very much
as a side project me and my daughter
ideating on what the next version of a
toy could look like in a digital format
so why do you think the Star Wars
characters special and All Star Wars
fans are going to really be into it yeah
and very much like you Justine I'm a
huge Star Wars fan I think if like you
look at my office the Star Wars
memorabilia all over the place I got my
Boba Fett helmets I got grogu chilling
over here I'm a big collector and a big
lover of all things Star Wars near and
dear to my heart I grew up with it this
team again we're over 60 people full
time it's filled with uh people that are
huge Star Wars fans and you'll see that
fandom come across in this product and
this experience this truly is a love
letter from Star Wars fans to Star Wars
fans uh and we just hope our fellow fans
love it as much as we do one thing I did
notice is the art style is so cute I
feel like you guys paid such attention
to detail can you talk to me a little
bit about like what all went into that
process yeah absolutely I mean shout
outs to our art and animation team they
are just absolutely Next Level and they
care so much about their craft that like
every detail is cared for and noticed uh
and accounted for and what they went
deep into the lore like there's just
attacks of Star Wars books and reference
material that they're incorporating into
these designs because they want to make
sure they get every single detail you
know and and also apply it to the
cryptos format as you know cryptoys have
their own style uh and unique kind of
form factor we want to make sure that
we're true to the the cryptos form
factor and also making sure we're true
to Star Wars Canon and lore and these
incredible incredible characters shout
outs to the the RN animation team they
really you know took this thing to the
next level and created something truly
special here thank you guys so much for
watching I am so excited about the
future of digital Collectibles
especially as someone who collects a lot
of physical toys and collectibles I'm
running out of room to put these things
so the fact that this is digital I can
bring it with me anywhere I go and the
fact that there are the possibilities of
upgrades because this is digital we
never know what's gonna happen there are
so many fun things that kryptoys has in
store for their future and they're gonna
be taking us and our toys along for the
ride if you guys are interested in the
chance of winning 110 holocrons we're
going to be sharing a sweepstake at the
end of this week I'll put a link in my
description if you want more info let me
know in the comments below who your
favorite Star Wars character is I think
that mine is probably Ahsoka I mean
she's not in this pack but like we can
only hope in the future that she will
also be a cryptoy like she's so cool she
freaking has like two lightsabers that
is like my that's my dream thank you
again I'll see you guys in the next
video bye
foreign
[Music]